[Music]
before we start this video I just wanted
to mention that only 15 percent of you
are subscribed so if you enjoy the
content please hit the subscribe button
to support the channel hey everyone
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in this video we're going
to be discussing Tom Riddle aka Lord
Voldemort murderer of The Potter's
nemesis of the Wizarding World and
master of dark magic in the year 1926
Voldemort was born Tom Marvolo riddle
the son of pure blood which Merapi gaunt
and wealthy muggle Tom Riddle senior his
mother Merapi gaunt was a member of the
pure blood gaunt family the gaunt family
were direct descendants of Salazar
Slytherin one of the extremely powerful
four founders of Hogwarts Merapi lived
with Marvolo gaunt her father and Tom's
grandfather as well as morphing gaunt
Voldemort's uncle the family lived in
extreme poverty the results of centuries
of inbreeding instability and violence
within the family Tom Riddle senior
hailed from the riddle family a wealthy
Michael family that had inhabited the
Angleton villages for many many years
the riddle family were disliked among
the townsfolk the result of snobbish and
arrogant behavior most likely stemming
from their wealth Voldemort was
conceived because his mother Merapi used
a love potion on his father Tom when
Merapi eventually released Tom from the
trance that he'd been placed under he
fled wanting nothing to do with Merapi
or his son this led to Merapi falling
into a deep and dark depression a state
that eventually brought her to wolves
orphanage in London it was a wolves
orphanage near 1926 the Lord Voldemort
was born he was named Tom Marvolo riddle
Tom after his father Marvolo after his
grandfather and riddle which was his
father's family name so being named
after your father or grandfather is
fairly common and the name Tom Marvolo
riddle is not particularly outlandish so
how did he get Voldemort out of that
where did the name Voldemort come from
Tom Riddle recognized at a very young
age that he was different than others
having caused all sorts of trouble at
Wars orphanage before eventually being
brought to Hogwarts by Professor Albus
Dumbledore because Tom was conceived by
a love potion he never had the capacity
to feel love or the emotions that a
normal person might feel
has led him down a very dark path a path
that he only embraced riddle obsessed
with where he'd come from began to
research his family history and
eventually came to understand his
relationship to Hogwarts founder Salazar
Slytherin he also connected the dots and
was able to figure out who his blood
family members were this brought him
back to little angleton the same town
that his father Tom Riddle senior as
well as the courts lived riddle angered
by the way that he and his mother had
been treated ended up murdering his in
his own words filthy muggle father and
placed the blame on his uncle Morphin
who was promptly sent to Azkaban
he then returned to Hogwarts and it was
at this time that he discovered the
Chamber of Secrets this only perpetuated
the dark path that he had begun to
follow and riddle recognizing that he
was the descendant of Slytherin set the
basilisk inside of the chamber of
secrets loose on students an attempt to
cleanse the school of Michael Baum's it
was at this time that Voldemort had
fully adopted the name Lord Voldemort as
by this point he had fully embraced the
darkness and no longer wanted to be
recognized by his father's name he had
put that part of his existence behind
him entirely and didn't want to be
associated with his father who he
believed to be a filthy muggle Tom
didn't like any of his names and was
very open about it from a very young age
in the half-blood prince riddle says to
Dumbledore there irritably there are a
lot of Tom's Voldemort had great
aspirations and wanted a name that was
anything but common for this reason his
new identity
Lord Voldemort was born Lord has in
positions of grandeur and a complete
lack of commonality and Voldemort just
sounds inherently sinister and fair in
siting in the Chamber of Secrets it is
revealed that Voldemort's full real name
Tom Marvolo riddle
is an anagram for I am Lord Voldemort
his name though it seems fairly
arbitrary actually makes sense in many
different ways let's start by breaking
down all of the aspects of his name to
see what he's getting at the first
explanation for his name which has been
confirmed by JK Rowling is that
Voldemort broken apart is full d'amour
which literally translates to theft of
death or flight of death in French many
believe that this choice of name is in
reference to Voldemort evasion of death
via the use of crisis by splitting
his
in two pieces well don't effectively
achieved immortality subsequently
stripping death of the capacity to take
Voldemort's lifeforce or soul in 2019
Rowling actually apologized to French
readers for naming the primary
antagonist and most evil character a
French name I want to thank my French
readers for not resenting my choice of a
French name for my evil character she
said in fluent French at a ceremony
during which she received the award from
President Nicolas Sarkozy I can assure
you that no anti-french feeling was had
the origin of this choice she said as a
Francophile I've always been proud of my
French blood but I needed a name that
evokes both power and exotic ism she
said a fall de menthe Voldemort himself
is 100% English she added while the name
Voldemort being French makes a lot of
sense it would be ignorant to ignore the
commonalities between Latin and French
as from a Latin standpoint we can drive
more about the name Lord Voldemort the
French language is survived from Latin
as it evolved in the area known to the
Romans as cool because of this most
French vocabulary comes from Latin they
just look and sound quite different
because the French language has
undergone a lot of phonetic changes
bearing that in mind let's break down
the name Voldemort from a Latin
perspective in Latin volt Walt's name
would be valo de morte Volo roughly
translates to by wish de is away from
and morte which is the ablative form of
more means death this would mean that
the name broken down literally
translates to I wish away from death
which effectively has the same meaning
as the French flight of death it all
just seems to point to one thing
Voldemort is trying to cheat death we
also see the Latin Moors in the spell
Morse madre which is an incantation used
by Lord Voldemort and his Death Eaters
to create an image of the dark mark the
dark mark is the cooling card of Death
Eaters and is usually cast over the
homes of anyone that they may have
killed or terrorized mort's madre broken
apart contains a Latin Mars which means
death and more death which means bite
bite of death who sounds sinister
continuing to break the name apart it is
also worth noting that Vold translates
to danger or violence into
languages such as Norwegian this in
conjunction with more which is death in
Latin gives off a kind of a danger death
vibe which simultaneously comes across
in two different families of languages
as such a large number of people would
be able to get in inherently dangerous
or deadly connotation from the name and
helped to give them a sense of what the
character is like before actually
becoming familiar with him the riddle
portion of Voldemort's original name Tom
Riddle has also been loosely tied to the
creation of his new name because Tom
Riddle's full name Tom Marvolo riddle is
an anagram for I am Lord Voldemort it
could be expressed that his name in and
of itself is a riddle which refers to an
enigma or brainteaser though it isn't
touched on publicly very often if you
dig deeply into the names of the
characters in Harry Potter you can
clearly see that there was a lot of
effort put in JK Rowling author linguist
and professed lover of the classics used
Latin and Greek roots in many places
throughout the series if you dig deep
enough you can see that most of the
names are quite with article e chosen we
can see this in the names of Sirius
which refers to alpha Canis Majoris or
the dog star Albus which is Latin for
white and alludes to Dumbledore's aged
and sagacious Ness Minerva which is the
goddess of wisdom and war in Greek
mythology Lupin which is related to
lupus or wolf in Latin and Alistair
which refers to the Avenger of evil
deeds in Greek mythology as you can see
all of these character names have roots
in Greek or Latin and did almost all
instances their names are extremely
fitting it's highly improbable the
relationships between these names and
their Greek or Latin associations came
out of the coincidence
in fact just researching this has
inspired me to make a full video on
etymology in Harry Potter one other
interesting fan theory that I've heard
of is that Voldemort was named after an
evil wizard named Voldemort as' who
hails from the legends of merlin
baltimore 'test means lord of evil and
the dark wizard Voldemort ists was
responsible for trying to destroy the
famous wizard Merlin from the time of
King Arthur Merlin a charms master
easily stopped Voldemort is
with a paralyzing charm and fed him to a
mythical beast one other theory that
have heard about Voldemort's name that
is a huge stretch is that because his
real name Tom comes from the name Thomas
which means twin he has a twin this one
is definitely a bit much for me however
I do think that it references the
commonality of the name Tom and
highlights Voldemort strong desire to
get away from that name in pursuit of
something more grand wherever his name
comes from and whichever meaning is most
applicable what I find most interesting
about his name is that there was
seemingly a lot involved when coming up
with it
I wonder if it was JK Rowling's
intention from the start to have I am
Lord Voldemort set up as an anagram for
Tom Marvolo riddle additionally it's
interesting that was such a heavy
behind-the-scenes focus on his name he's
referred to by other names for the
majority of the books and films
everyone's saying you know who the Dark
Lord and He Who Must Not Be Named
but Voldemort only the bravest or
perhaps most foolish seemed to be saying
that regardless of what he's called
there's one thing that we all need to
remember fear of a name only increases
fear of the thing itself and that's it
for this video if you enjoy the content
please be sure to like the video and
subscribe to the channel if you have any
questions or thoughts about his name
then feel free to comment them down
below until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]
you